techstar CEO says 2023 will be a
graveyard for startups and the problem
is entrepreneurs just aren't making
money you've got a big mission a big
Vision Big Dreams amazing you want to
change the world let's go I'm here for
it but you have to learn how to make
money or your dream will never happen
the easiest way to get started here's a
trick is you start a service-based
business most people start product-based
businesses that take too long to develop
and take too much investment too much
Capital to get off the ground and they
end up going broke in the process start
a service based business but Evan I'm
trading my time for money I don't want
to do that yes that's exactly what you
want to do at the beginning at the
beginning of your business you trade
your time for money you start a coaching
business you start a Consulting business
you start a service based business you
trade your time for money so that you
have money in your bank account and then
you can use to go build your Empire so
many people are off just trying to build
an Empire just trying to think about
leverage that they go bankrupt in the
process you can't change the world if
you don't have any money